relational databases using sql are king
in my recent poll nearly two-thirds of
viewers said that sql was their go-to
database
and that's despite the fact that it's 40
year old tech with billions of dollars
invested in disruptive technologies that
try to knock sql off its throne today
you'll learn everything you need to know
about mysql an
open source database that powers content
management systems like wordpress
ecommerce platforms like shopify
and social media giants like twitter
we'll take a hands-on approach by
recreating airbnb's database which
happens to use mysql in real life in the
process you'll learn why sql is so
popular
how to install and interact with the
database using modern tooling and vs
code the essential syntax to create read
update and delete data and most
importantly how to model and
join relational data there's also
another giveaway with this video the
mysql pillow all you have to do is be a
subscriber and leave a comment below
to start things off let's travel back in
time 50 years to meet ted codd
the author of the legendary paper a
relational model of data for
large shared data banks prior to this
paper databases were not relational
they were network-based or hierarchical
in the paper he outlines how a
relational model can reduce duplication
and redundancy and it changed the way
people would approach databases going
forward
a few years later donald chamberlain and
raymond boyce would use this paper as
the basis for developing
structured query language aka sql or sql
and is the language we still use today
to interact with data in a wide variety
of relational databases
but now i need to let you in on a little
secret and that's the fact that most
developers using relational databases
aren't actually writing raw sql code
more often they use libraries that
perform
object relational mapping which are
tools that allow you to work with
relational databases
using the object-oriented programming
language of your choice javascript has
sqlize python has
alchemy and ruby on rails has active
record orms make it so you never have to
touch raw sql code and that can actually
be a great thing for productivity most
of the time
but learning how raw sql works will help
you understand some of the magic that an
orm does under the hood and that's what
this video is all about
when i say the word relational database
i'm talking about a relational database
management system
which is comprised of two main things
you have the database itself which is a
collection of tables and in each table
you have your actual data organized in
columns and rows
very similar to an excel spreadsheet the
second component in the system
is a language used to manipulate and
read data in the database
which is most often a variation of
structured query language
in addition to mysql there are many
popular database options out there
like postgres sql server sql lite and
tools like cockroachdb that can easily
be distributed on the cloud to scale
high traffic apps
now let's take a look at the data model
for our airbnb clone using a tool called
drawsql which can help you visualize and
model data relationships we'll refer
back to this diagram throughout the
video
but all you need to know for right now
is that each one of these boxes here
represents a database table then the
lines between them represent different
relationships like one-to-one or
one-to-many
what we're looking at here is the
database schema which is basically a
blueprint that defines the different
rules or constraints within the database
if we look at a table you'll notice that
it's a dictionary where the key
represents a column in the database
and the value represents a data type
that can be stored there
there are many different data types and
they can vary between different sql
databases
but for the most part they just
represent different types of numbers and
strings
like in mysql we have int for integer or
float for floating point numbers for
small strings we might use
varchar or varchar if you prefer or use
text for
longer strings you don't need to know
all the data types at the beginning
but choosing the right one will help you
optimize the size and performance of
your database when you build a serious
app
in addition to a data type a column
might also have a special constraint
a column may not be able to store a null
value or maybe each value in that column
needs to be unique
in this schema you'll notice that every
table has an id
with the primary key constraint which
means that it cannot be null
and it must be unique that ensures that
every row in the table can be identified
that's essential when building
relationships because that unique id
can then be saved on another table to
represent a one-to-one
or one-to-many relationship like a user
can have many rooms
and a room can have many reviews and
we'll look at that in more detail later
in the video
now the other thing i want to point out
in this diagram is that there is very
little data duplication between the
tables
every table is a unique entity which
means that the rooms table for example
doesn't need to store any information
about the user just a reference to the
user id
we call this a normalized data structure
because every entity
is organized into its smallest normal
form a concept that ted cod laid out
over half a century ago for example we
have a bookings table that requires
information about a user and a room we
could save user data and room data on
that table but that would result in a
lot of data duplication
a better approach is to separate users
and rooms into their own entities
then join them back together with
bookings when needed a great analogy is
that normalized data is like breaking
down a car
into all of its individual parts when it
comes time to build a car you just join
all those parts back together
okay so now that we know a little bit
about sql from a high level
it's time to get hands-on by first
installing mysql
on our system i use arch by the way but
for this video we'll install mysql on
windows
if you go to the website there's an
installer that you can download go ahead
and download it
and the only thing you need for this
tutorial is mysql server
go ahead and stick with the default
settings for everything then it will ask
you to create a password
make sure to remember the password
because we'll need it later to connect
to the database
then the installer should take care of
everything else to configure your system
if you're on a mac there's also an
installer you can download that follows
the same process or you can just use
homebrew
after the installation is done you
should then have access to the mysql
command from the command line
now to access the database from the
command line you'll run mysql
followed by the u flag for username and
then also add flag p
if you used a password we now have
access to mysql
in the command line and the first thing
we'll want to do is create a database
we can do that by executing an sql
statement that says
create database followed by the database
name which in this case will be airbnb
we can then verify that it was actually
created by typing
show databases now we could do this
entire tutorial from the command line
but that wouldn't be very developer
friendly
a better option is to install the sql
tools extension for vs code
it allows us to store our connection
details visualize the database
and view a history of all the queries
that we've run to set it up just install
the extension and driver for mysql
and then create a new connection you
should be able to stick to the default
settings
just make sure to add the name of the
database you just created along with
your username and password
go ahead and test the connection and
hopefully you get a success message
otherwise google is your best friend now
go ahead and click the button to connect
and we're ready to start writing some
code to build out this database
the first thing i want to point out is
that you can create a comment in sql
using a double dash a cool thing about
this vs code extension
is that if we create a comment followed
by at block it will put a play button on
top of that statement
allowing us to run it individually so we
don't have to jump around to a bunch of
different files
at this point we've already created a
database now we just need to add the
first table to it
which can be accomplished with a create
table statement now a couple things to
note here
a statement is code that does something
and we know this is a statement because
it ends with a semicolon
the words highlighted in purple are sql
keywords they're reserved words that the
language will interpret to do something
by convention we write them in uppercase
but they're actually not case sensitive
and we could write them in lowercase if
we wanted to
the third word users is known as an
identifier
and in this case it just identifies the
name of the table
inside the parentheses we can add a list
of columns that we want to include on
this table
in this case we have an id email bio and
country
those are the column identifiers or
names but they also need to have a data
type
and optionally one or more constraints
let's give the id field an
integer data type which means we can
only store whole numbers here
no decimals or strings the data type is
important because if you try to save the
wrong data to that column
the database will throw an error because
sql is very strict about data integrity
next we'll add a constraint to this
column called primarykey what that tells
the database
is that this column identifies a unique
row therefore the id must be unique
and must not be null constraints are
kind of like an extra layer of data
validation that you can add beyond just
the data type
one additional constraint that you'll
often see on ids is auto increment
this tells the database to automatically
create the id for you
it'll start at 1 then increment to 2 3 4
and so on from there we have email which
is a string value
so we'll give it a type of varchar it
takes an argument of a number that
represents the maximum length that
string can be
you'll often see it set to 255 because
that's the max amount of characters that
can be counted with an 8-bit number
so adding one more character would just
be a waste of a byte
the email column will also have a
constraint of not null
that means there has to be something
added to the email field on every row
and we'll also add the unique constraint
to ensure that every email is unique now
moving on to the bio we need to
potentially store a much larger string
here
so instead of varchar we'll use text
which can store a string value of an
unspecified size
and lastly we have the country value
which is also a string but in this case
we know the country code will always be
two characters
so we'll go ahead and enforce that rule
on the data type we're now ready to
execute this sql statement by pushing
the play button
you should get a success message back
then if you open up the vs code
extension
you should be able to see the schema for
this table in the ide
now that we have a table it's time to
insert data or rows into it the way we
do that is with an insert into
statement we reference the user's table
with its identifier then in parentheses
add the columns that we want to update
the order of the columns is important
because after that we have values which
is a list of values that should be
inserted into these columns the first
value is the email the second is the bio
and the third is the country
one thing you might notice is that i'm
leaving out the id field because if you
remember from the last step
we added auto increment to it so it's
going to be created by mysql
automatically if i go ahead and run the
query you'll notice i get an error back
that says the value used for the country
is too long if you remember earlier we
gave it a max length of two
so because it has three characters here
it's not allowed to write that data to
the database
when we change it back to two characters
the query then runs successfully
that inserted the first row into the
database and it's also worth noting
that you can insert multiple rows at the
same time by separating them with commas
so now that we have some data in the
database the question becomes how do we
retrieve it
or query it a select statement allows us
to read data in the database
and have it returned to us in a result
table if we want to read an entire table
we can say select
star from the users table that will
return the entire table
along with every single column but in
most cases you are not going to want all
that data
you can filter out columns by simply
separating them with
commas in the select statement for
example we might only want the email and
id
in the result set but a table might also
have millions upon millions of rows
an easy way to limit the number of rows
returned is to use the limit keyword
followed by the number of rows that you
want notice how only two rows are return
now
but what if we want them to be ordered
by a certain field like a timestamp or
id
we can achieve that by adding an order
by clause that specifies a column we
want to order by
then ascending or descending based on
the direction of ordering
ordering is useful but you'll often need
to filter out rows with more complex
logic
sql starts to feel more like a real
programming language when you introduce
the where clause
for example we may only want the rows
that have a country code of us
a where clause allows us to run
conditional logic on the query
in this case it will only return rows
where the country equals us
we can also chain additional conditions
to it using and
or or like where the country equals us
and the id
is greater than one but in some cases
you may not want to filter by an exact
value but rather a pattern
like maybe you want all the emails that
start with an h
in which case you can say where email
like
followed by a pattern in this case it'll
find all the columns where the email
starts with an
h we get two results back from that
query but if we change the pattern to
hello
then we only get one result back so like
is kind of like a basic
full text search feature the problem
with this query though is that it's
going to become very slow as our data
set grows larger
if you need to retrieve data quickly
you'll need an index which is basically
a lookup table that allows you to
retrieve data faster
a database index is just like the index
in the back of a textbook
it helps the database find important
keywords without having to scan the
entire data set
but it comes at a cost of slower rights
and the requirement of additional memory
in this case though we'll definitely
want an index on the email field which
we can do
by creating a statement that says create
index which will give a name of
email index and point it to the users
table email
column and now when making a query for
the email based on a pattern
it should be much faster now that we
have our users table set up we're ready
to create our first relationship
if you're a host on airbnb you might
have multiple properties available
so the relationship is that a user can
have many rooms
or a one-to-many relationship between
users and rooms
let's go ahead and write a query to
create another table called rooms
it has an id field for the room itself
but also notice how it has an owner id
field
that represents the landlord or the id
of the user who owns this room
the id of the room is our primary key
then the owner id
is known as a foreign key because it
references an id
in a different table on the next line we
can set up the primary key by pointing
it to the id field
then we can do the same thing for the
foreign key but we also need to tell it
which table and column to reference
which in this case will be the user's
table id column
when you set up a foreign key constraint
like this it tells the database
not to delete anything that holds data
about that relationship
so that means it'll be impossible to
delete users who have an associated room
at the same time
in other words you're guaranteed to have
data integrity let's go ahead and create
the table
and then we'll need to insert some data
into it i'm using an insert into
statement
just like we did in the previous example
and notice how i'm setting the owner id
to one
that means that the user with an id of
one owns these four properties
and now we're ready to make our first
relational query using a join
in this case we want to query the users
that own rooms
and include some information about each
room that they own
there are four different types of joins
inner left
right and outer to understand the
difference you first need to understand
that when you make a join
you're reading data from two different
tables think of users as the left table
and rooms as the right table when you
perform a join you'll be matching the
user id
to the owner id on a room so the
relationship will only exist between
certain rows on each table the type of
join you use will determine whether or
not
data with a corresponding relationship
will still be returned in the query
let's take a look at a few examples
first we'll say select everything from
the users table
then run an inner join for rooms on the
condition where the room owner id
equals the user id that gives us a
result set with four rows in it one for
each room that has a corresponding owner
in this case the owner is the same for
every room but each row
has also been joined with the room data
now in some cases you may want to fetch
all the users even if they don't have an
associated room
you can do that with a left join this
time the result set has three more rows
for the other users
but all the room data is just null as
you might imagine
a right join is the exact opposite of
this it would return all the rooms that
don't have an associated owner
and lastly you have a full outer join
which actually isn't supported in mysql
but it would look something like this in
other databases now one thing you'll
notice in the result set
is that when we have conflicting column
names in the join mysql will
automatically rename them for us
like it did with user's id and room's id
you can easily change that
by selecting a specific column then use
the as operator
to cast it to a different name let's use
underscores to make the name more
friendly with programming languages that
use dot notation
that's pretty cool but there's one more
big question that we need to answer with
our data model and that is how does a
user
book a room from another user we can
model that relationship
by creating a third intermediate table
called reservations or bookings
most importantly a row in the bookings
table will have
a check in time along with a guest id or
user id
and the room id both of which are
foreign keys
that allows us to create complex
relationships where a user has reserved
many rooms through the bookings table
or on the other side a room has many
past guests through the bookings table
once we have that data model established
we can then run joins through the
bookings table
for example we can get all the rooms a
user has booked by joining rooms to
bookings and filtering by the guest id
or we can get a history of all the
guests who stayed in a room by joining
users to bookings
and filtering by the room id and that's
all you need to know about databases to
build a multi-billion dollar startup
actually wait there is one last thing i
forgot to show you but you need to be
careful with this one because if you use
it incorrectly you could delete your
entire database and lose a lot of money
a drop statement allows you to delete
data like an individual table or an
entire database in fact youtube uses
mysql under the hood so i should be able
to delete this video by clicking